porchetta is a super salty fatty
boneless pork roast stuffed with tons of
garlic herbs and lemon it's so good
hi I'm Matthew Francis I'm a tasty
producer and I'm going to show you how
to make classic porchetta from the tasty
ultimate cookbook first you're going to
want to prep your pork belly a full day
before you cook the porchetta now I know
this seemed like a ton of sugar and salt
but trust me don't freak out you need
this much of the seasoning to flavor all
of this meat and after it rests for a
full 24 hours in the fridge you rinse
off all the seasoning before it's ready
to be cooked this process it's called
dry brining dry brining the pork belly
for a full 24 hours really allows those
flavor enhancers to draw out moisture
and soak into the meat growing up only
my dad or my grandpa could make the
porchetta and they were watched like a
hawk by my super Italian great-grandma
Lulu I was never allowed to even touch
it but then when I came back for
Christmas after my freshman year of
crawlin Airy school I challenged my dad
that I could do a great job just like
him then eventually he gave it the whole
family loved it they loved it but now
because of all that I have to make it
every single year this garlic herb and
lemon paste is so flavorful as the
porchetta slowly cooks in the oven it
perfumes all of that meat and I can't
even describe it it's incredible
I moved far away from home to start
working in restaurants when I was 18 and
the only time I'm able to come home is
for Christmas so cooking food for my
family is my way of showing them how
much they mean to me I love those bozos
more than anything so now a fresh pork
loin is wrapped up in this pork belly it
allows the final product to have both
that super crispy skin you need on the
outside and perfect tender juicy pork in
the center it is so important to tie
your porchetta correctly I lay all the
long strings of twine on the bottom
place the porchetta on top and then tie
the meat by drawing the strings over
creating a loop with two fingers to
create a slip knot tighten that as much
as you can then create a second knot to
hold
place this step is vital to making sure
your pork cook fully evenly and looks
desirable when you try and wow your
family at a dinner table cut off the
excess string and you're good to go if
you tie up perfectly even porchetta it's
just gonna make the end product so
pretty so now the porchetta is ready to
be cooked low and slow in the oven do
this about maybe four hours before your
guests arrive that way you're not
stressed or in a rush when they show up
then you take it out get rid of some of
that fat that will melt off and then you
put it back in the oven at a higher
temperature for a short time to get that
perfect crispy skin this process is
similar to reverse searing reverse
searing is a perfect trick to cook
expensive meats that you're scared to
mess up because you don't want it to be
wrong inside or burnt on the outside
since porchetta has a thick layer of fat
and skin the intense dry heat breaks
open the fat cells and puffs the skin up
and that's how you get the beautiful
crackling and then by the time your
family arrives and they're hungry the
porchetta should be rested and ready to
eat this bad boy is a showstopper for
sure everyone is gonna be like oh my god
I can't believe you made that but you
can do it it's not that hard I know you
can my family we sort of just eyeball
everything so I'm just so excited we
have the classic recipe in our new
cookbook tasty ultimate it's good
because my family will now stop arguing
about the minor details and just let me
make it in peace if you do get the book
and make this bruschetta
let me know because trust me you're
never gonna want to go back to life
without it it's that good
the skin is so crispy it crunches the
garlic and the herbs perfume the whole
entire house and the center of that pork
just melts in your mouth
every Christmas I just have to have
it's perfect oh yes